北京我们SUGHAI
从前年的秋天到现在
今天是北京演唱会的第三场
也是我歌手生涯的一个里程碑
我第一次一连开三场
我们一起唱
我们一起笑
也一起感动
让我们一起先把这份点放在心里
今天不是结束
是等冬天再见面
咖啡tell me啊
羡慕吧
哈哈哈啊哈
♪ 哈请注意身体 ♪
♪ 立马给的告白 ♪
这位是朱朱老师你好
我们这次happy loving呢这个全新改编的歌曲啊
主要是猪猪老师做编舞
大家知道他是谁吗
记得吗
一直有在发了
我的歌迷们有看浪姐
她有那位漂亮温柔
但是坚定的要求的老师
在这里我们有漂亮的舞台
就是因为她漂亮的编舞
吉他温柔又坚定的要求
欢迎欢迎派派派
我们欢迎你
好可爱啊
key太高了
就我的意思是说
那个大屏那张纸几乎只剩我的屁股
这样行了
非常好看啊是吗
好的好的
不需要多一点屁股吗
哈哈很紧张诶
看到的都是你的美貌
哇哇有拍到吗
被撩了
被个漂亮的人撩
因为我昨天吐了
但是我也不知道我是为什么吐
因为我跟所有同事吃的东西都一样
但只有我吐
我也没有多吃什么
其它多喝什么
其他的东西我就一下台
其实在唱最后那几首歌的时候
我在台上就有点想吐
然后但是一直忍住就一下台的时候
我就给姜蓉姐一抹微笑
说我好想吐
昨天大概一点吐了四次
白手术会是我今天的好朋友
连夜这个有医生护士的协助之下
现在好多了
这么热烈啊
还好点吗
是那怎么办
今天没发烧
你就打点滴
我每次生病都上班诶
就去安顿party
对我心里想说
哎呀天哪
F的话
你还能喝酒吗
谢谢啦
还写了一个rap
重点是
所以说这个舞是比较难的
嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿
只是觉得一起跳舞应该蛮可爱的
可以啊
亚洲舞男的没有没有亚洲舞男
谢谢位呵呵
开心可以了
开心可以让我们欢迎周深
谢谢听说你很怕人家叫你宝贝
求求你了
爱人专一
所以他其实是有点害羞的
比较内向对
虽然他就是平常的那个反应都很很很快速
但他确实他其实是爱人
所以我们现在眼睛闭闭
不用这样
我虽然就是爱人
但不是见不得人
你可以教我怎么快速开嗓吗
我我我现在在在紧张
说话都有点说不清
嘿嘿嘿
♪ 都快忘了怎样恋一个爱 ♪
♪ 我被虚度了的青春 ♪
♪ 也许还能活过来 ♪
♪ 说心疼我的更应该明白 ♪
♪ 我当然会沉醉个痛快 ♪
终于身边看着我
我好紧张啊哈哈
恨不忘心
场子也太热了吧
老大我给你红
活该
这个巡演卖到爆啊
你这首歌很难唱
你这首歌就是难唱
都藏在意别人感受到过多好
你这你这首歌就是很需要内力
我是说真的
我看看周深老师说这首歌是真的真的难唱
真的好
唱的真多难唱
谢谢周深
开心啊
当然会沉醉心还听吗
对呀我也是想象觉得会很好听
就是深深一定会帮大明
这首歌就是我加倍加深好听的这个美好的效果
很及开心一样
♪ Happy loving ♪
♪ 我要你开心 ♪
♪ 好的坏的对的错的 ♪
♪ 只要是你 ♪
♪ Oh happy loving ♪
♪ 没有季节限定 ♪
♪ 我不会缺席 ♪
当你觉得伤心一天是H小姐
昨天是P先生
今天是Z先生
所以很开心
北京场有这三个不一样的嘉宾来到这里
希望你们都会喜欢你的
眼里轻轻闭着
可可能当你唱歌看我想念你
♪ 那么你从来不知道想你 ♪
让你也能穿越时空
♪ 想对你说 ♪
我
回复主宰
哇哈哈怎么办呢
就是完成了三场直播
放个暑假都有那么一丝丝不敢想
真的修格兰要闭园的时候
可能大家真的会很舍不得
哎我现在不敢往下想
但是我们只是先放暑假
然后很快冬天就再跟大家见面了
第一次唱三场
觉得对自己很棒
就是很尽力
希望你们都开心